[Applaudissements]
en exclusivité c'est un agriculteur
voilà qui n'a pas été diffusée cette
année alors même si je vous ai envoyé
des images nous ont demandé de vous
montrer ce portrait je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'est une surprise pour vous
n'avez jamais vu cet agriculteur
regardez
[Musique]
christophe est éleveur de pigeons en
région parisienne c'est grâce à lui que
plus de 12 millions de parisiens ont
chaque jour la joie de croiser ces
magnifiques vues relatives à la voile à
ce grand artiste de 49 ans est un
véritable passionné
[Musique]
il nous fait découvrir le lieu où il
aime se ressourcer pendant sa pause
déjeuner pour savoir
nous lui avons demandé ses goûts en
matière de femmes par exemple vous
l'avez compris notre agriculteur au
grand coeur cherche la femme de sa vie
alors si vous avez craqué pour ce
magnifique mâle n'hésitez pas à nous
écrire
christophe aime les pigeons est le lui
rendent bien
[Applaudissements]
il est là il est là ce choix ce garçon
fait des critiques de cinéma